a lot of people believe that max
strength is the ultimate foundation of
athletic performance this is because
having more max strength means you have
a greater reserve to draw on whenever
you exert power explosiveness speed
in theory the more strength you have the
greater your capacity to move quickly
powerfully or strongly
however i believe that strength
endurance is actually more important
strength endurance being your ability to
contract a muscle and exert force
repeatedly over time without fatigue or
without getting gassed out so if you
think about any sport whether it's
martial arts whether it's rock climbing
whether it's football or something else
in rock climbing you need to pull your
entire body weight for a considerable
amount of time whether going straight up
or traversing across in this video i'm
hopefully going to convince you why you
need to be training your strength
endurance specifically and i'm going to
talk you through how to do it it's
freezing and it's dark but i'm low on
time the show must go on and a huge
thank you this week to my sponsor yes
i've got a sponsor magic spoon and i'll
talk to you more about them soon but
they make fantastic healthy cereal that
tastes genuinely delicious
yeah so you might agree with me that you
need a lot of strength endurance to
perform a number of daily tasks however
you might disagree that you need to
train this specifically and some people
say that as long as you're training max
strength you don't actually need to
train for strength endurance as well on
top of that the reasoning behind this is
fairly logical but as we'll see in a
moment i think it's somewhat flawed so
the argument goes that if you have a
very very strong max bench press say say
you can bench press 200 kilograms then
you're tasked with bench pressing 10
reps of 100 kilograms well you're gonna
do that a lot better than an endurance
athlete because to you 100 kilograms is
relatively easy compared to your usual
200 kilograms so you can stand a chance
of performing 10 reps of 100 kilograms
gonna have more and stronger muscle
fiber you're going to fatigue less
quickly and therefore you can exert both
strength in a single instance of acute
power or in the long term but my issue
with this theory is if you take that
person can do the 200 kilogram bench
press and then you get them to do say
200 push-ups well now they might start
to struggle more at the same time
they're certainly going to struggle to
perform a high number of repetitions of
75 kilograms versus say a bodybuilder
who's used to doing higher rep ranges
and if you put them in a ring and get
them to spa they're still going to get
burned out a lot more quickly
so there's a number of reasons for this
but it comes down to specific
adaptations to improve demands in other
words the specificity principle in
training the bench presser can bench
press a lot not only because they have
more and stronger fast twitch muscle
fiber in the necessary muscles but also
because they're moving in a more
efficient manner they're not losing as
much energy because they've practiced
this movement over and over again and
they can perform it perfectly however
they are lacking certain adaptations
that would be beneficial were they
crawling whether doing push-ups whether
using battle rapes
in particular something that might
really be missing is slow twitch muscle
fiber so slow twitch muscle fiber as we
know is type one muscle fiber this is
the slower contracting muscle fiber it's
not as strong but it's more energy
efficient and you can use it for longer
durations you can use it as part of your
aerobic energy system and so a lot of
strength athletes will intuitively avoid
training their slow twitch fibers
because they're trying to get stronger
they want to build the biggest and
strongest muscle fiber why would they be
interested in training thinner and
weaker fiber but there are a few issues
with this argument the first is that
actually per square inch slow twitch
muscle fiber is about as strong as fast
twitch muscle fiber that is to say that
one really thick fast twitch muscle
fiber is about as strong as a bunch of
thinner slow twitch muscle fibers at the
same time slow switch muscle fiber does
produce a lot of force and seeing as we
don't exert that much more than 40 or 50
percent of our maximum effort in nearly
any sport there's not really that much
argument for ignoring slow-twitch muscle
fiber that is contributing a large
amount of power to any lift or any
movement and in fact you can't lift a
large amount of weight or move very
quickly without engaging a whole bunch
of slow twitch fibers and this is due to
henneman's size principle we engage
motor units and muscle fibers in the
reverse size order so you'll start with
the smallest one and get bigger as you
need them but at the same time it's hard
to fatigue those slow switch muscle
fibers so if you're only ever lifting
heavy weights then you'll only ever
fatigue and challenge the big fast
twitch muscle fibers the big motor units
and those slot muscle fibers won't get
as strong as powerful as they could be
now when you're bench pressing 75
kilograms or 50 kilograms or 40
kilograms for a high number of rep
ranges what will happen to the person
who only trains for max strength is that
those big fast trained fast twitch
fibers will eventually tire out and drop
out of the race but they won't have as
many slow switch fibers they won't be as
well trained there to continue
performing and continue producing a good
amount of effort to keep going in those
higher rep ranges preval satsulin has a
great article on this that i've talked
about in the past and i will link to
that in the description down below i
highly recommend that you check it out
so as you can see in order to train slow
twitch muscle fibers and therefore gain
more muscle endurance you need to train
differently from just training for your
max strength obviously one way you can
do this is to lower the weight
or perform something like lots and lots
of push-ups however if you really want
to train slow twitch fiber you also need
to go slowly or include isometric holds
and the reason for this is once again
that henneman size principle remember
you recruit the size of motor unit the
size of twitch muscle fiber that you
need in order to exert the amount of
force necessary to complete the task so
if you're doing a fast explosive push-up
you're going to need more fast twitch
muscle fiber when you run out of steam
when those fast twitch muscle fibers
fatigue you won't be able to perform any
more repetitions if you're going very
slowly however you don't need those fast
twitch muscle fibers and therefore you
can go past the point where you'd
otherwise fail and start to really
challenge the slow twitch fiber another
option is to use isometrics we are
simply holding a position just being a
yielding isometric this time so you
might just get into a a low halfway down
push-up position and hold that pose
until you completely collapse and once
again because you're just holding a
position you can use your slow twitch
fibers to go for as long as you possibly
can and a lot of calisthenics athletes
unknowingly train primarily slow twitch
fibers which is why you might see some
of them not be quite as explosive
despite having that incredible strength
control but my favorite strategy that i
like to use to train all my muscle
fibers is the drop set so let's say
you're performing as many repetitions as
you can of a bench press you could do
maybe you know five reps of 120
kilograms then you're going to drop down
immediately to say 100 kilograms to
perform a few more reps drop down
immediately to say 50 kilograms and
perform as many as you can 25 kilograms
and then just keep going to failure
using a slow tempo and lots of control
and what you're doing here is training
and fatiguing those fast stretch muscle
fibers so that they're out of the
picture then you're training just those
slow twitch muscle fibers these are long
sets and you're training not only max
strength but also muscle endurance and
that's how i do 90 of my training and
it's worked really well for me and for a
lot of other people that i've trained
with
or you can use a slight variation of
this that i like to use which is to
perform say 100 push-ups and then just
to hold an isometric push-up position
for a good minute or as long as i can go
before i drop to the ground so as i
mentioned at the start of this video
guys i have a sponsor today that being
magic spoon cereal
the idea is that you get all the fun of
eating a sweet delicious cereal but none
of the calories none of the sugar and
it's just a healthy and wholesome way to
enjoy that experience it comes with zero
grams of sugar four grams of carbs and
13 grams of protein my favorite is the
the fruity version
they're also keto friendly gluten free
soy free grain free and low carb
and each portion is only 140 calories
no
click the link below to get your variety
pack today and don't forget to use the
promo code super functional to get five
dollars off of any order or go to
www.magicspoon.com forward slash super
functional and magic spoon is so
confident in its product that it comes
with a 100 money back guarantee so if
you don't like it for whatever reason
you can get a full refund no questions
asked so click the link below and use
the promo code super functional to get
five dollars off of any order today or
go to magicspoon.com forward slash super
functional taking sponsors like this is
fantastic for the channel because it
means that i can make more content like
this without worrying so much about the
algorithm and clicks thanks once again
to magic spoon for sponsoring this video
and now on with the show
so the really interesting thing about
all this is that we don't actually know
exactly what causes muscle fatigue what
causes muscles to fail what we do know
is that more muscle equals more glycogen
in other words if you have bigger
muscles you can store more glycogen and
you can go for longer bodybuilders who
train specifically for hypertrophy who
aim for muscle size will automatically
be capable of larger rep ranges because
they have more muscle and a bigger
resource to draw from
[Music]
large rep ranges work because they give
us metabolic stress as well as muscle
damage and these are two great signals
that trigger muscle growth with that
said of course the glycogen lactic acid
system also creates more metabolic waste
products that contribute to muscle
fatigue we used to think that lactate
was responsible for this sensation of
burn that would interfere with our
ability to contract our muscles however
we now know that lactate is not the
enemy lactate in fact gets shuttled away
from the muscles and then converted back
into pyruvate and back into glucose and
ions are thought to contribute to
acidity that might interfere with
contractions however this isn't 100
either in fact some studies looking at
acidity levels in the muscles find that
they generally remain within acceptable
limits even when we're fatigued so it's
unlikely that that's fully responsible
for muscle fatigue either and the really
interesting thing is that we don't know
100 what actually causes muscle fatigue
there are many other factors that may
play a role such as ionic changes to the
excitation contraction coupling and many
more chances are it's a combination of
these things however what we do know is
that a better circulatory system is
going to help you to get rid of waste
products and provide your muscles with
the nutrients they need and this leads
me nicely onto the other aspect of
strength endurance which is just
endurance you know cardio aerobic
fitness and you're going to find that
weightlifting and strength training is
far more metabolically demanding than
many people recognize and so you need to
be training your overall endurance your
heart rate your stroke volume your vo2
max your circulation if you're going to
perform at your best in the gym this
will allow you to get in more high
quality volume leading to greater
strength even if you're not interested
in functional performance in sports and
in life if you just want to be stronger
and look bigger then you need to work on
your aerobic fitness on your lungs on
your endurance you can do this by
combining your training with a little
bit of cardio or you can do it by
training for longer rep ranges or you
can do it by taking shorter rest periods
in the gym or by being more active
during your rest periods engaging in
some other kind of active recovery this
might mean you have more central fatigue
during your workouts however you'll be
able to train more in the long run which
will mean you get stronger over time and
i think it's a worthy hit it'll help you
to recover it'll give you more work
capacity it'll give you more energy in
the gym to train harder for longer so
that each workout is better quality and
more importantly you'll be able to exert
that strength in the real world whether
it's in sports or whether it's just you
know working in your garden of course
the best type of finisher to my mind is
the resistance cardio finisher that
being things like battle ropes or med
ball slams even super high repetition
push-ups this way you're able to
challenge your cardiovascular system but
at the same time you're still working
those muscles and you're contributing to
metabolic build-up metabolic stress
within the muscles that you just trained
but do bear in mind that many of these
adaptations are specific they're
localized to the muscles that you're
using so if you want to get better at
swimming then running a lot isn't going
to be as efficient as swimming a lot
because you have adaptations to your
muscle fiber to your blood supply to
your mitochondria within the muscles
that you're using when you swim if you
want to get better at martial arts then
train in the gym using the same muscles
that you'll be using when you train
martial
arts so you found this video useful
interesting guys let me know in the
comments down below what you think about
training strength endurance is an
important part of your training and how
do you go about targeting it a huge
thank you once again to magic spoon for
sponsoring this video if you're
interested in this kind of training that
goes beyond just aesthetics beyond just
numbers in the gym and looks at instead
overall functional performance then you
might enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training
there's a link to that in description
down below and it's currently on
discount either way thank you so much
for watching this one guys subscribe if
you want more like it hit the bell
button for notifications and i'll see
you next time
bye for now